first time I saw him Aleph ascent in the
imax format it just blew me away I shall
bestow a gift on the child I grew up
being such a fan of the format actually
see a product that I was involved with
so deeply projected it at this scale it
was overwhelming I've always loved the
character Maleficent I used to draw that
out of a book my father gave me and
listen character it is so iconic
we didn't really want to take something
that was already so good and reinvent
that so hard of going into it with
Angelina was okay let's make that
character and then add more layers to
that and peel off those layers and see
what else was going on in her mind and
her backstory why did she become evil we
find that out in our phone
the imax format her character is going
to go to a level that i didn't think it
was possible to experience the design of
the film is really important to me we
had to gather the troops very quickly
and fully design a world a challenge
beyond anything I'd done before but we
like big things we like challenges it
was a little bit like designing two
separate worlds is it true here
Maleficent I wanted to be a distinction
between humans and fairy world when you
see in the imax format the scope that
you can get in the depth and the details
is truly remarkable
what I've learned over the years is that
the experience is fully complete when
you can be immersed in a product imax
allows you to be drawn into the film do
you feel more attached to it and somehow
involved in it it's a really important
aspect to why we go to movies